today's meeting was an important
opportunity to reaffirm the European
Union's commitment to the New Republic
of Moldova process of political
association and economic integration
this association Council allowed us to
discuss in particular the link between
the implementation of the association
agreement and the national reform agenda
of the government of Moldova we
discussed reforms in specific key
sectors and noted the glows link between
the country's goals and modernization
and deposits of political association
and economic integration the U stands
ready to continue supporting all the way
with understanding that multiple
authorities take ownership of the
development of their country 2017 should
be the year when these new beginnings in
the sphere of reforms should give the
first benefits to the citizens of 2016
was a year of stabilization for Arsenal
2017 should be a year for growth and
investment before our association
council today we made one step further
in order to intensify cooperation in the
area of security together with the high
representative mogherini and we signed
an agreement on security procedures in
the exchange of classified information
or for most of us stays committed in its
pathway towards the European Union's